Russische Welt 15 vor der Schule Blackies
Wie gefällt dir diese russische Welt?
[Musik]
Mariupol Burlyaev wird heute sein
andere Harvest Aviation Empfänger
Artillerie
Volley-System-Projekt, an das er sich erinnert
Mariupol-Wert wurde sein nicht ein Jahrhundert
Ich verteidige, ob die Krieger der Ehemann derjenigen wurden, die wegnehmen
am Baron schließe ich die ganze Ukraine, versuche es
für meine Erfahrung werden sie meine Felder für das Jahr finden
Ukraine
[Musik]
Wir haben heute Morgen die Bestätigung erhalten
aus der Russischen Föderation vom Ministerium
verteidigung der russischen föderation, die passieren
von Mariupol bis zur Stadt Saporoschje Wora
Dnjepr ist mit solchen Schildern sicher
mit der Unterstützung des Roten Kreuzes müssen wir
fuhren Richtung Stadt
Leider Saporischschja
der Moment, in dem wir schon bereit waren, begann
Beschuss der regulären Armee des Russen
Föderation entlang des Korridors entlang der
wir mussten umziehen
Ich kann auffangen und ich bin zu Hause
next next sie ist da, du verlierst so für
me verbietet barren ab 14 hand und und
Hexenfrauen, du bist nicht er, sie haben ihn weggenommen
noch mehr von ihren Kindern, unseren Flüssen, kannten wir
Und
[Musik]
hier ist der hof
Entbindungsheim
[Musik]
Kinder waren die Summe aller
andra
[Musik]
Beschuss
neues Haus
[Musik]